ah ah j'espère que vous allez bien moi
c'est tout mais ses attaques
voilà j'espère que vous allez bien c'est
un petit peu compliqué je sais pas où
est ce qu a habité dans le monde si vous
êtes en france si vous êtes en belgique
si vous êtes en suisse si vous êtes
n'importe où dans le monde
mais ici en france ou pas si ça vous
aurait échappé et bien c'est le
confinement à partir d'aujourd'hui mêlée
parce que oui quand je tourne on n'est
même pas un monstre on est le mardi
mardi mardi 17 mars et il est 14 heures
18 ça c'est l'heure à laquelle je tourne
cette vidéo sera publié demain matin 7h
sur youtube comme ça on est très
ponctuel très clair et ici c'est le
confinement pour éviter la propagation
du comité 19 coronavirus et vous
connaissez l'histoire j'ai pas vouloir
faire tout le monde en parle en boucle
mais c'est extrêmement importante donc
dans un premier temps je vous avais bien
évidemment et je redis les âges que tout
le monde dit restez chez vous ne sortez
pas de chez vous protégez vous protéger
les autres ça c'est le premier point
mais surtout je voulais vous parler de
l'avenir de la chaîne par rapport à
toutes ces problématiques la revoir un
peu ce qu'il en est parce que vous le
savez si vous me suivez
eh bien je suis toujours emmenés à
bouger à droite à gauche pour aller voir
les nouveautés tech voir les nouveautés
produits que je reçois que je teste
je suis souvent par monts et par vaux
sauf que là avec un confinement et avec
la situation actuelle c'est relativement
compliqué donc je reste ici je fais ma
part je travaille à la maison ça me pose
pas de problème
je voulais donc vous dire que suis déjà
d'une très content moi de pouvoir
travailler depuis chez moi de pouvoir
communiquer avec vous grâce à cette
jolie petite caméra et ça c'est vraiment
bien je suis pas vraiment vous soyez au
rendez vous pour qu'on puisse justement
continuer à parler tech
mais juste avant qu'on commence à être
période un peu délicate je voulais faire
un point avec vous et aussi vous mettre
à contribution
si vous le souhaitez alors je vous
explique déjà on va faire tout tout tout
premier point j'ai fait une vidéo pour
vous donner les bonnes astuces les
bonnes méthodes pour venir nettoyer vos
objets technologiques et notamment pour
éviter les contaminations jeu les mises
en ligne pour essayer de faire ma part
d'apporter ma modeste pierre à l'édifice
donc cette vidéo est en ligne vous
pouvez la consulter son à chaîne sans
aucun problème
et bien évidemment 2 par la situation
actuelle pleins de lancement qui était
prévu tous les produits que j'ai reçue
sous embargo c'est à dire les produits
que je reçois en avance pour sortir la
vidéo le jour où l'annoncé officielle
est fait et le moment où j'ai le droit
de le faire et bien ces produits-là
reste au chaud bien côté je ne peux pas
vous en parler ya donc eu pas mal de
partenariat qui sont pour l'instant en
stand by plein de belles choses que je
devais vous montrer qui pour l'instant
reste de côté on en parlera
j'imagine prochainement mais pas tout de
suite donc c'est normal
d'un côté aussi un petit peu frustrant
parce que j'ai tellement de trucs dont
on a envie de vous parler
je ne peux pas mais malgré tout ça il ya
quand même quelques produits que j'ai
avec moi donc je ne vous ai pas encore
parlé tessa notamment à g le corps t4 de
crosse cole c'est la dernière tablette
de crosse cols dont je voulais vous
parler
j'ai le corps 6 4 c'est le smartphone de
crosse coll sauf que le core ix catch
les prêter un ami et que malheureusement
vu la situation je ne peux pas y
récupérer donc je ne pourrais pas vous
en parler tout de suite désolé puis
désole quand ce qu elle aussi un petit
peu rien produit que j'ai depuis
longtemps et là c'est vraiment vraiment
de ma faute je veux c'est un prodige est
ronde et depuis très longtemps je suis
vraiment très impatient de tester et
j'ai perdu beaucoup de temps parce que
je voulais vraiment prendre le temps de
bien le connaître en détail et comme je
cours toujours un peu partout à droite à
gauche c'est un peu compliqué c'est ce
produit là c'est la gopro max que je
trouve tout simplement fabuleuse
vraiment extraordinaire justement j'ai
eu le temps de vous en parler donc ça
c'est cool on en reparle très très très
très prochainement si vous êtes créateur
de contenu ou si vous voulez devenir ça
franchement c'est un outil qui est au
top
je vous en parle extrêmement rapidement
j'ai également aussi un casque de
marshall dont je vais vous parler dans
quelques temps côté ordinateur on va
parler d'un concept d de la serre et
puis il ya deux vidéos que j'ai tourné à
new york lorsque j'étais il ya quelques
jours des vidéos qui vous parle de
produits de base extrêmement intéressant
et ça normalement ça pourrait également
arriver dans quelques jours voilà donc
pour la partie test il ya d'autres
produits qui pourraient potentiellement
arriver si les livraisons se font si ces
services là sont toujours assurés pour
l'instant ça reste un petit peu flou en
tout cas si ça arrive
croyez moi on en reparlera et ça ça va
être hyper cool mais justement il ya
plein d'autres sujets dont je vous ai
pas parlé dont je voulais vous parler et
c'est l'occasion on va sauter donc sur
l'occasion comme un garçon très positif
on va saisir se confirmant comme une
opportunité pour pouvoir parler de plein
de sujets intéressants dont je voulais
vous parler mais j'avais pas le temps
toujours un peu complexe je vais donc
vous donner plein d'astuces et de tutos
sais pas si vous connaissez bien la
chaîne et si vous allez sur la playlist
et vous regardez plutôt et astuces vous
verrez qu'un à quelques-unes et vu le
nombre de vues de certaines vidéos je
pense que derrière il ya une attente
vous avez besoin de conseils vous avez
besoin d'astuces dans différents
domaines
et justement je voulais vous consulté à
ce sujet quels sont vos besoins de quoi
est ce que vous voulez qu'on parle pas
forcément pour aller acheter un produit
parce que on pourrait parler de
comparatifs quelle différence entre tel
et tel produit
c'est vraiment pas là dessus que ça va
s'axer c'est vraiment plus pour vous
aider dans des problématiques que vous
avez au quotidien des problématiques qui
vont être liés à votre mac votre pc à
votre smartphone pour récupérer des deux
né pour nettoyer ça pourrait être des
questions comment savoir si on a un
virus comment supprimer un virus
ça peut être des problèmes de connexion
internet à la maison ça peut être plein
de problèmes toujours lié à l'univers de
la tech donc si vous vous avez des
problèmes marqué le mois en bas en
commentaire je me fera plaisir m'en
parler et de pouvoir vous aider
et puis un troisième point dont je veux
vous parler c'est comme on les confiner
chez nous et comme il faut bien
évidemment qu'on respecte tout ce
confinement
on a une situation qui est un petit peu
particulière on à la maison peut
rapidement tourner en rond et je voulais
savoir comment ça se passait chez vous
j'espère que vous allez bien
j'espère que tout se passe bien pour
vous j'espère que vos proches ne sont
pas malades ne sont pas afin j'espère
que si c'est le cas ils vont guérir au
plus vite et que ça va se passer pour le
mieux qu'à maladive être très rapidement
endiguée mais si ça n'a plutôt pas mal
chez vous et que vous avez un petit peu
de temps libre
eh bien pourquoi ne pas partager notre
quotidien ensemble et voir un peu
comment ça se passe ce qu'on peut donc
faire si ça vous intéresse c'est chez
vous vous prenez votre smartphone vous
filmer dans ce petit format là et vous
m'envoyer vos vidéos qui me montre et
qui m'explique votre vie au quotidien
alors une vidéo de pas plus de deux
minutes mais ça pourrait être
intéressant de voir comment s'organise
que ce soit pour travailler télétravail
à la maison comment vous arrivez à
survivre ensemble
est ce que le couple va plutôt pas mal
est ce qu'il risque d'avoir des divorces
comment est-ce que vous gérez avec les
enfants et si vous vivez seul comment
est-ce que vous survivez seul chez vous
sans avoir de contact physique avec
d'autres personnes
si vous souhaitez comme envoyer tout ça
j'ai créé un email que je vous mets
juste là c'est amour
@ monsieur gros point fr je savais pas
comment appeler cette adresse email mais
je me suis dit que le mieux en cette
période c'était de s'envoyer de l'amour
donc je les appelais amour @ monsieur
creux point fr vous pouvez donc m'en
voyez toutes vos vidéos par ouï
transfert jusqu'à 2g gratuitement il ya
d'autres services qui existent ne
m'envoyez pas vos vidéos directement par
email mais qu'il y ait vraiment des
services comme we transfert qui marche
très bien et qui sont gratuits que vous
soyez créateurs de contenus youtube
heures instagram heures que nous vous
soyez sur aucune plateforme aucune que
ce soit pas votre métier que vous soyez
comptable profs élèves et étudiants à la
retraite que vous soyez dans un ehpad
vous pouvez m'envoyer vos vidéos très
courtes pas plus de deux minutes et je
les publierai au début de chacune de mes
vidéos pendant le confinement à chaque
fois qu'ils auront une vidéo qui sortira
tout au début il y aura une personne qui
sera là qui vous montrera comment il vit
chez elle le but c'est d'être plus
proches les uns des autres de se
recentrer
ensemble et partager parce que c'est
très important de sentir beaucoup au sol
pendant cette période qui que vous soyez
quel que soit votre métier quelle que
soit votre activité vous pouvez y aller
vous m'en voyez ça et dans cette période
tant que j'aurai des vidéos à partager
je le ferai en ce qui concerne l'envoi
de l'eau liées au concours pour
l'instant c'est bloqué malheureusement
mais rassurez vous donc le confinement
élevé tout ça va partir toute la partie
recrutement qui est lié au moteur est
pour l'instant également bloqué peut pas
recevoir des gens on ne peut pas
discuter là dessus puisqu'on est confiné
jeu bien évidemment écrire toutes les
personnes qui ont postulé pour leur
expliquer la situation et bien
évidemment il n'y aura pas de présence
au studio à paris puisque voyez je ne
peux pas y aller je ne peux pas me
déplacer je reste à la maison ce qui est
complètement normal donc on va continuer
à faire plein de vidéos ici on est quand
même plutôt pas mal
voilà sur ce j'espère que vous allez
bien dit moi aussi comment vous allez en
bas on commentaires comment ça se passe
chez vous et puis surtout dit mot
vraiment de quoi vous voulez qu'on passe
si vous avez des envies particulières et
mais pourquoi pas des petits pots logis
de vidéos que je n'aurais pas encore
imaginer ou encore vu vous pouvez y
aller pour mes marques et tout ça endort
commentaires je me ferais un grand
plaisir d'en parler puisque je suis
avant tout à votre service voilà sur ce
je vous embrasse
j'espère que vous portez bien j'espère
que vos proches sont bien j'espère que
c'est pas trop difficile j'imagine que
ça va être compliqué d'un point de vue
psychologique des tout le temps chez soi
c'est le début il faut le faire on fait
notre part et puis dans quelques mois on
sera posée à la terrasse d'un café et on
en rigole en raison fin tu te souviens
quand on était comme des cons la maison
voilà c'est passé maintenant tout va
mieux allez je vous embrasse
à demain
[Musique]
à
mais bon
legacy locker
nas m